you interviewed Olympians haha on NBC
for the yeah that's a great honor that
they asked you to do that was for for
the Internet is that correct it's both
the Internet all the ones and zeros
enjoyed it so many times I didn't really
meet in the Olympic ins yes yes and you
actually you we have a picture of you
here talking to Michael Phelps of course
we're gonna talk to you seem excited I
am 98% he is a 62 do you get into any
Olympic sports or any that you
particularly love yes I'm very much
loved in modern pentathlon have you
heard of this and I'm not familiar it's
real and sassy there are five sports
it's like the Pentagon but not a
government it's sports okay alright
there's a laser shooting there is horsey
riding there's sorta fighting jogging
and then more swords
yeah that's a real thing that's all
reels does not Game of Thrones wait so
this is a thing that people do is they
they ride and they get off the horse and
they shoot lasers I'm God and people and
more horses which country is best do you
know at this game I am a called a blind
I don't see race :
they are all very wonderful you don't
see race you don't see you don't need
wood you don't know what nationalities
were participating but the flags have
many designs and stripes and stars Conan
it's confusing okay all right what's all
about Germany Germany is very good at
soccer
oh we are good yeah you're very good at
that what do you think of the US soccer
team had less success it is very sad it
is like if you go to the bakery and
you're like I will have eight cupcakes
and then you receive a salad
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay that is American soccer right there
yes yes if you Wikipedia that is the
entry okay so you don't think you don't
think our soccer is that good no it's
it's just a different it is like looking
at animals and looking at humans and
then there's a moose and the Moose is
they are staring as animals in the
humans why is the moose their play more
American football okay moose okay why is
easier - what is your favorite American
sport I love very much basketball hoop
nasty dunk dunk you know okay now this
is you have a favorite basketball player
yeah of course Jeff Novitzky ya know why
yes Dirk the visca you have a picture
here yeah yes yes actions the mouthpiece
yeah he must be a big hero in Germany
he's a very large hero in the size of
physics and biology and also in the same
ways yes so you like you you're big fan
of Dirk Nowitzki's I lived it very hard
and the problem is I say dear can
everyone is it is theack you guys are
like Dirk its Dirk no it's duck well
that we can't say it that way I do why
you cannot say dick because if you say
it quickly it sounds like great oh it's
like he is a deity
he's like the Moses of Hoops yeah come
on dunk it hardcore shooter shooter
Swisher
dear hey dear yeah yeah oh you know it
okay it started coming up and down to
the intestines
okay alright let's you watched you watch
American football you like football I
love all of those things with the Piggy
skin and the men running around
I'm confused so Conan there's like
always much waiting and talking and
who's what in the little huddle and what
use the sirs the old number number
Tootsie Tootsie and they're only two
seconds of action it's very little
action but when there's excitement
there's a lot of excitement so much
screams and then a toss and then
everyone is in a large large Hill what
do people piling up together sorry
yeah so blurry I don't have HD Conan I'm
sorry okay and then yeah I do have teams
that you like there's the dolphins
there's the you know yeah okay so I like
the enemy the ones that are like oh if
it was in the sport watch out if it
disappear the pair can eat you your day
is your knee bye bye Mike Singletary's
anchor you know so you like a team it's
named after an animal that would
actually be fierce on a football field
yes why is the Dawson's
[Laughter]
okay what about and it's on land
yeah what about the Panthers oh boy
watch out Brower oh you know what I have
been you wanted to go Rory Rose now Rory
row no no you don't have to break it
down into all those syllabus but all
there but you only sing one thing I must
call a football player or riru so go
give Conan I don't understand
same what I love it
you